Visit Indeed.com/Hire
and get started today.
>> Harris: PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS
DECIDED HE’S GOING AFTER
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS ACCUSING
THEM ARE UNDERMINING VACCINE
MANDATE, ENTAILS FORCED
BUSINESSES WITH MORE THAN 100
EMPLOYEES TO REQUIRE
SHORT-STAFFED PEOPLE TO GET THE
SHOT OR UNDERGO WEEKLY COVID
TESTING AND KEEP AN EYE ON THE
DOOR TO MAKE SURE EVERYBODY HAS
A VAX CARD.
THE PRESIDENT CLAIMS REPUBLICANS
ARE THE ISSUE.
QUINNIPIAC POLL FINDS 51% OF
AMERICANS DISAPPROVE OF HIS
MANDATE.
SOME IN THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA ARE
REPORTING AND FOLLOWING
PRESIDENT BIDEN’S LEAD WITH THIS
US VERSUS THEM APPROACH.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE HAVE TO STOP CODDELING
PEOPLE WHEN IT COMES TO THIS AND
THE VACCINE SAYING YOU CAN’T
SHAME THEM OR CALL THEM STUPID
OR SILLY.
YES, THEY ARE.  THE PEOPLE WHO
AID AND ABETTED TRUMP ARE STUPID
BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE HIS BIG
LIE, PEOPLE NOT GETTING VACCINES
BELIEVING LIES ON THE INTERNET,
INSTEAD OF SCIENCE, IT IS TIME
TO START SHAMING THEM OR LEAVING
THEM BEHIND.
THEY ARE KEEPING THE MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS BEHIND.
>> Harris: YOU WANT TO LEAVE
PEOPLE BEHIND DON LEMON, THEY
MAKE UP HEALTHY PERCENTAGE OF
PEOPLE WHO DECIDE THEY WILL
REMAIN UNVACCINATED.
THE HYPOCRISY HERE, MY OTHER
FAVORITE WORD STARTS WITH H,
TOO.
NOT GOING TO SAY THAT.
MORGAN.
>> Morgan: SO MUCH TO UNPACK, MY
MIND WENT TO IT, YOU TALKED
ABOUT NIKKI MINAGE AND HER
TWEETS, WHAT WAS INTERESTING,
THE TWEETS WERE RIDICULOUS, WHAT
WAS MORE APPALLING WAS THE
REACTION AND THE INSTINCT FROM
CERTAIN PEOPLE ON THE LEFT TO
SHAME NO MATTER WHAT, INSTEAD OF
TRYING TO EDUCATE.
AS YOU SAID, HARRIS, IT IS ALL
ABOUT HYPOCRISY, WHERE IS THE
PRESIDENT CRITICIZING REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS, WHY NOT CRITICIZE THE
MET GALA, WHERE THE ELITE WERE
UNMASKED, BUT NOT THE STAFF, OR
THE PRESIDENT’S JULY 4 PARTY
PICNIC HE HAD AT THE WHITE
HOUSE, THAT I BELIEVE THE
"WASHINGTON POST" REPORTED HAD
SEVERAL HUNDRED PEOPLE IN
ATTENDANCE.
IT IS JUST ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
RULES FOR THEE, BUT NOT FOR ME
AND CLEARLY THE PRESIDENT
DECIDED THIS IS A POLITICAL
FIGHT HE WANTS TO HAVE, GO AFTER
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS, ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHO MAY CHALLENGE HIM IN
2024.
>> Harris: BEN, THIS IS
LOW-HANGING FRUIT, IF YOU MAKE
IT ABOUT POLITICS AND GO AFTER
TRUMP SUPPORTERS, YOU DON’T HAVE
TO TALK ABOUT PEOPLE WHO LOOK
LIKE DON LEMON AND JOY REID AND
MYSELF.
I DON’T WANT TO OVERSELL IT, WE
PAID HIGHEST PRICE, 57% OF
DEATHS, PEOPLE OF COLOR, WE KNOW
WE ARE VULNERABLE TO THIS
DISEASE, RATHER THAN REACH OUT
AND TRY TO HELP, IT IS FURTHER
DIVISION IN THIS COUNTRY.
YOU DON’T HAVE TO KNOW HOW
PEOPLE VOTE TO KNOW THEY HAVE
THEIR OWN SEPARATE IDEA ABOUT
BEING VACCINATED OR NOT.
THEY ARE INTELLIGENT.
>> Ben: THIS IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST AND SICKEST POLITICAL
MOVES I’VE SEEN IN MY LIFETIME.
>> Harris: IT’S CRUEL.
>> Ben: DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
WHITE HOUSE UNDERSTAND THEY NEED
A WEDGE ISSUE TO DIVIDE THE
COUNTRY ON PURPOSE.
LET ME REMIND DON LEMON, WE’RE
NOT ANTI-VAX CONSERVATIVES, WE
CAME UP WITH THE VACCINE, WE
DID, OPERATION WARP SPEED.
DONALD TRUMP IS THE ONE THAT
MOVED US FORWARD AND YOU GUYS
WERE ON TV GOING, I’M NOT TAKING
THE TRUMP VACCINE, I’M SORRY, I
DON’T BUY IT THERE.
GO BACK TO THE WHITE HOUSE
DECISION, THEY DECIDED WE HAVE A
DISASTER, DUMPSTER FIRE IN
AFGHANISTAN WITH 10% OF
AMERICANS LEFT BEHIND, DUMPSTER
FIRE WITH THE ECONOMY RIGHT NOW,
HOW DO WE GALVANIZE OUR BASE AND
MAKE SURE POLL NUMBERS STOP
FALLING?
THEY SAID, HERE IS WHAT WE’RE
GOING TO DO, GO OUT IN AMERICA
AND DIVIDE BASED ON POLITICS ON
COVID-19 VACCINE.
DO NOT TAKE THEIR BAIT.
REMEMBER THE AMERICANS IN
AFGHANISTAN, REMEMBER WHAT
THEY’RE DOING TO OUR ECONOMY, I
TRULY BELIEVE THE CONSTITUTION
WILL SAVE US ON THIS ONE, I
BELIEVE STATES WILL WIN ON THIS
ONE.
THIS IS A SICK POLITICAL MOVE.
SOLELY TO SHORE UP HIS BASE TO
SAY HATE THE REPUBLICANS,
THEY’RE WHY YOU’RE DIEING AND
THAT IS NOT FACTS HERE.
>> Harris: I WILL GO THERE, YOU
USED THE H WORD I WAS TALKING
ABOUT, I DON’T LIKE TO PUT TERMS
LIKE THIS HERE, IT IS HATE.
IT IS DRIVEN BY HATE, HYPOCRISY
AND HATE.
WHY?
CASE
>> Kayleigh: EXACTLY WHAT BEN
SAID, WE ARE HAVING SIM BIOTIC
MOMENT, BEN, HE IS RIGHT, THEY
ARE USING HATE AND DIVISION TO
DISTRACT FROM ALL OF THE
MULTIPLE CRISIS IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> Harris: SO HOW CAN YOU
LEGITIMATELY SAY YOU ARE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE WHOLE UNITED
STATES WHEN 70 MILLION DIDN’T
VOTE FOR YOU AND YOU WANT TO
LEVERAGE HATE TOWARD THEM AND
THEY ARE NOT, MANY OF THEM ARE
VACCINATED.
>> Kayleigh: YEAH.
>> Harris: WHERE IS THIS COMING
FROM?
>> Kayleigh: GREAT UNITER AND
CHIEF, INSTEAD DIVIDER IN CHIEF.
DON LEMON, BOY, HE’S PROBABLY
AUDITIONING TO BE SPEECH WRITER
WITH THAT MAFIA-LIKE LANGUAGE.
VACCINATED HAVE A RIGHT TO BE
ANGRY, HE WANTS TO FIGHT WITH
GOVERNORS, AS HE VACATIONS, HE’S
ON A PLANE NOW GOING ON
VACATION, HE WANTS TO DISTRACT.
>> Harris: EMILY.
>> Emily: IT IS APPALLING
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF HAS ANGER
TOWARD THE AMERICANS.
HE CALLED THE TALIBAN
CHALLENGING, HE SAID CONDEMN THE
UNVACCINATED.
WE HAVE DON LEMON CALLING
UNVACCINATED STUPID, FELLOW
AMERICANS WITH LEGITIMATE
QUESTIONS WEE TALKED ABOUT
YESTERDAY.
>> Harris: I THOUGHT YOU WERE
SMARTER -- WE DON’T KNOW HOW
THEY VOTE.
>> Kayleigh: IT FLOWS FROM THE
TOP, INVITED CELEBRITY WITH
QUESTIONS TO COME TO THE WHITE
HOUSE TO ENGAGE WITH HER AND